would you like to experience the
darkness of Pluto well you already do
twice a day on Pluto the sun would
appear a thousand times dimmer than it
does from Earth but that's still 300
times brighter than the full moon so you
could easily read a book on Pluto during
the day but you can experience the
brightness of a Pluto day right here on
Earth every day just Before Sunrise and
just after Sunset it is as bright on
Earth as it is at noon on Pluto NASA
calls these moments Pluto time and
they've put together a calculator that
can tell you exactly when your next
Pluto time is if you go outside at that
time you can get a feeling for Pluto
life that is the brightest it gets
during the day on Pluto but my favorite
thing about the Pluto time calculator is
that there's a by the Numbers section
that compares Pluto and Earth Pluto was
discovered in 1930 but when was Earth
discovered
[Music]